[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein blech
voller erfrischender multivitamin
schnitten
[Musik]
wie schnitten sind sehr einfach in der
zubereitung sehen aber dennoch total
aufwendig aus wegen den ganzen leckeren
schichten und die erste schicht ist der
rührteig und jetzt zeige ich euch
zuallererst die zutaten dafür
wir benötigen ja ja die haben
raumtemperatur außerdem mehl zucker eine
prise salz vanille extrakt oder vanille
zucker etwas multivitaminsaft neutrales
öl ich hab rapsöl genommen und
backpulver
[Musik]
für die zubereitung geben wir die eier
die prise salz und den zucker in die
küchenmaschine und schlagen das fünf bis
sechs minuten schön hell cremig
wer keine küchenmaschine da hat der kann
auch sein handrührgerät verwenden dann
dauert das ganze noch etwas länger
[Musik]
nachdem die eier masse richtig schön
hell cremig geschlagen wurde geben wir
die flüssigen zutaten mit ins so also
das öl der multivitaminsaft und auch
dass vanille extrakt
wer stattdessen vanille zucker verwendet
kann das ganz am anfang mit dazugeben
und sobald die zutaten ganz kurz
untergerührt wurden geht es schon weiter
mit den trockenen zutaten
[Musik]
ich gebe das mehl und backpulver immer
gerne durch ein sieb damit auch keine
klümpchen entstehen
[Musik]
für die trockenen zutaten gilt dasselbe
wären sie nur so lange unter bis sie
sich mit dem restlichen teig verbunden
haben und dann ist der rührteig auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
auf mein tiefes backblech habe ich jetzt
backpapier gelegt und damit die ränder
auch schön gerade und gleichmäßig werden
meinen eckigen back rahmen
den könnt ihr natürlich weglassen das
ist gar kein problem nur so müsst ihr am
rand später nichts mehr wegschneiden
jetzt gebe ich den teig da rein und
verteilen mit meiner winkel palette
[Musik]
der teig wird jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 180 grad für etwa 13
minuten gebacken jetzt geht es weiter
mit der nächsten schicht hierfür
benötigen wir multivitaminsaft etwas
zucker und speisestärke
[Musik]
nun werden alle drei zutaten in einem
kochtopf miteinander verrührt den herz
schaltet die an der stelle noch nicht
ein
wir werden das ganze zunächst erst mal
kalt verrühren
[Musik]
mit dem schneebesen funktioniert das am
besten und sobald das ganze dann
krönchen frei ist kochen wir das einmal
unter ständigem rühren auf
nach dem aufkochen dick der
multivitaminsaft ein und wir können den
herd ausschalten
noch ist der saft dickflüssig und fließt
herunter sobald allerdings kalt wird ist
er dann schön schnittfest damit die
masse nicht ganz so heiß ist dürfte sie
jetzt etwa zehn minuten herunter kühlen
und ich habe dabei auch ständig
umgerührt damit sich keine haut bildet
der teig ist nach dem backen schön
goldbraun hier ist auch noch nicht ganz
abgeklungen team also auch schon lauwarm
weiterverwenden und dann verteilen wir
die multivitamin schicht darüber und
verstreichen das mit einer winkel
palette schön glatt
[Musik]
nach dem verstreichen muss dann das
ganze vollständig auskühlen damit wir
auch bedenkenlos die sahne schicht
darüber geben können ohne dass uns was
verläuft die können wir aber inzwischen
schon vorbereiten hierfür benötigen wir
kalte schlagsahne doppel rahmen
frischkäse etwas puderzucker seine stand
mittel und vanille extrakt oder
vanillezucker und auch hier haben wir
wieder die einfachste zubereitung der
welt gegeben alle zutaten in die
rührschüssel und schlagen das dann steif
ihr solltet nur darauf achten dass die
sahne gekühlt ist ich nehme sie immer
direkt aus dem kühlschrank und wenn ich
zeit habe lege ich sogar auch mal gerne
meine schüsse und den schneebesen in den
kühlschrank damit die auch schön kalt
sind und dann kann ja nichts mehr
schiefgehen
[Musik]
alles dann kurz auf höchster stufe
geschlagen ist die creme auch schon
fertig und kann bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
gegeben werden
[Musik]
für die weiterverarbeitung ist es
wichtig dass der kuchen vollständig
ausgekühlt wurde
jetzt geben wir die sahne creme darüber
und verteilen sie mit einer winkel
palette schön glatt
[Musik]
unsere dritte schicht ist somit fertig
und ihr müsst auch nicht so gerade und
glatt arbeiten denn es kommt ja die
vierte schicht darüber
hierfür benötigen wir löffelbiskuits und
um sie zu trinken etwas multivitaminsaft
[Musik]
nun werden die löffelbiskuits mit der
einen hälfte in den multivitaminsaft
getunkt und dann auf die torte gegeben
hierfür reicht es wenn ihr sie wirklich
nur bis zur hälfte ein punkt denn der
saft der dringt durch den ganzen text
durch und der keks wird auch noch mal
durch die sahne schicht weich
[Musik]
falls ihr persönlich einen absoluten
lieblings saft habt dann könnt ihr
selbstverständlich auch gerne den
verwenden
[Musik]
für die letzte reihe habe ich die
löffelbiskuits noch mal an der spitze
abgeschnitten damit sie aufpassen und
jetzt fehlt nur noch die deko ich habe
hier weiße kuvertüre verwendet die habe
ich mir ganz einfach geschmolzen und in
einen spritzbeutel gefüllt um dann von
lee spitze abzuschneiden
[Musik]
sobald die schnitten eine stunde lang
ziehen durften sind sie auch schon
fertig und ihr könnt sie endlich
servieren
ich persönlich finde sie total schön und
sind richtiges highlight auf jeder
kaffeetafel
falls ihr also demnächst gäste erwartet
oder einen geburtstag feiert dann darf
die multivitamin schnitte oft gar keinen
fall fehlen
[Musik]
geschnitten sind super weich total
frucht dich und einfach einzigartig
empfehle sie wirklich jedem nachzumachen
schaut gern mal unten in die infobox da
habe ich für euch nochmal alle zutaten
und mengenangaben aufgeschrieben
[Musik]
falls ihr noch kein abonnent meines
kanal zeit dann solltet ihr das ganz
schnell nachholen damit ihr auch nichts
mehr von mir verpasst
außerdem freue ich mich wie immer über
eure nachgemacht fotos auf instagram mit
dem herrscht der ggs kitchen
jetzt wünsche ich euch noch ganz viel
spaß im nachbacken und freue mich aufs
nächste mal tschüss
[Musik]